what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are gonna be going
over every disaster level dragon and God
monster in one punch man and their
powers I'm especially excited for this
one because the villains always have the
best backstories just so you know the
levels are as follows from weakest to
strongest wolf tiger demon dragon and
God so in this video we're going to be
discussing all the strongest villains
including villains that could even be
considered God level threats but before
we get into that - make sure to smash
that like button if you like seeing one
punch man videos on this channel if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you actually
get notified when new videos drop in
this video there will be some manga and
webcomic spoilers you've been warned
now without further ado let's look at
the most powerful monsters in the world
of one punch man so what does it mean to
be categorized as disaster level dragon
anyways well disaster level Dragon is
reserved for monsters or other things
that pose a threat to multiple cities
while disaster level god monsters pose a
threat to the survival of humanity in
general first off we have vaccine man
AKA purple piccolo he exists because of
humankind's constant pollution of the
environment he believes that the earth
is a single living organism and humans
are the germs that are killing it in his
view the will of the earth gave birth to
him
so that he could destroy humanity
usually you might think that a hero for
fun wouldn't stand a chance against
someone with such a well-developed
purpose and yet the hero for fun kills
him with one punch so much for the
Earth's impossible vaccine man can fly
shoot energy balls and transform like he
really is straight out of Dragon Ball Z
however he definitely didn't have as
much staying power as regular piccolo
next we have carnage kanuto the giant
bug man his shell is said to be an
impenetrable fortress he was the house
of evolutions strongest creation in
physical traits and intelligence he far
surpassed the human race at the time
jenos was completely outmatched by the
monster his breath alone could overpower
one of Genesis strongest attacks all of
this God's item I excited to fight
carnage starts out brimming with
confidence
but just as he's going to hit Saitama he
jumps back something that Saitama would
have killed him if he did it he gets
credit for something that's almost true
power at the very least but then carnage
goes full Evangelion mode and musters up
all of his power to attack Saitama
Saitama panics but only because he
remembers that it's Saturday and that
he's missing great deals at the
supermarket he finishes the buff
pinnacle of human science with a simple
absent-minded punch causing dr. Janus to
say that he's done with experiments next
we have melzar guard probably the most
freaky looking character in the entire
series he was a general in forces alien
army melzar Garza's entrance is pretty
dope he easily kills the sky king by
swatting him like an act he can
regenerate from sword cuts like it's
nothing unfortunately we can't say the
same for the medieval armor samurai who
permanently loses his left arm to this
dragon level creature Melser guard can
split up into five bodies or combine
them all for max strength and damage the
way to kill him is to find the five orbs
in his body and destroy them it's like
trying to find a needle in a haystack
while that haystack is trying to kill
you another really cool power is this
shape-shifting that allows him to grow
wings or even weapons it took the
combined efforts of s-class heroes like
silver Fang metal bat pooty pooty
prisoner atomic samurai and even
tatsumaki to defeat this ever
regenerating Beast next we have grody
bus the thing with jaws for hands it can
release acid breath that can melt you
however he only has time to let Saitama
know that he's going to release his
deadly acid breath attack before side to
my effortlessly punches his head off at
least sight them I waited for him to
finish talking next we have get Egon
shoot the right hand alien man of Boros
he has octopus like tentacles he claims
to be the strongest psychic in the
universe and can use psychokinesis to
eliminate the friction between objects
and air so the objects like rocks can
attain insane speeds without evaporating
not even best girl tatsumaki can do that
the psychic alien octopus sends
countless rocks out Saitama without
doing any damage then the hero for fun
throws one back
it immediately kills the so-called
strongest psychic in the universe next
we have the superior to the previously
mentioned aliens Boros the alien super
saiyan himself he also calls himself the
Dominator of the universe the creator of
one punch man one has said that Boros is
beyond dragon level but he hasn't
officially been characterized as God
either meaning he could be somewhere in
between dragon and God in truth he
probably should be considered a God
level threat because Boros said his
finishing move would blow away the
planet surface which would definitely be
a threat to the survival of humanity in
general Boros is a lot like an alien
version of Saitama according to him
there was no one in the universe left
for him to face so he was born a seer
had a prophecy 20 years ago that
Burroughs could enjoy a challenging
fight on earth so he came in the hopes
of a worthy opponent this time one
normal punch is not enough to kill
Burroughs just to destroy his armor that
holds in his overwhelming power his hair
in each one of his transformations
reflects a Super Saiyan form first
it's like Super Saiyan thank Super
Saiyan 2 and then the longer haired
Super Saiyan 3 he gets progressively
stronger and faster and his hits can
launch site dama all the way to the moon
even if they don't significantly hurt
him his species is supposed to be the
greatest natural healing in the universe
he can recover from consecutive normal
punches which is unheard of up to this
point he can fire energy blast like it's
Dragon Ball Z as mentioned his final
attack which releases all his energy can
supposedly blow away the entire Earth's
surface unfortunately for him though
Saitama manages to stop the attack and
kill burrows with the air pressure from
one of his serious punches Boros
definitely got the challenge he wished
for but Saitama had strength to spare
next we have Baku Zhan go ketsu believes
that Baku Zhan is dragon level after his
monster transformation buck was on was a
strong human martial artist with a wild
unibrow and very bushy sideburns he
chose to become a monster in order to
become stronger instead of taking one
monster style he takes a bunch
he eventually transforms and immediately
becomes arrogant again he even claims
that he'll kill go ketsu if he gets in
his way
although go ketsu quickly shows the gap
between their strength then ba cusan
realizes that he doesn't
to be the strongest he just likes to
torment people weaker than him like
sewer ooh-hoo he used to envy when he
was human
luckily sweetie gets rescued by Saitama
who effortlessly takes out half a buck
who's on body killing him in the process
even before he took the monster cells
Baku Zhou was referred to as the
strongest man in the history of super
fight he used the martial arts style
dark hell assassination which included
cool moves like bear killer mid kick he
was known for ending fights in a brutal
bloodbath the monster cells greatly
increased his already impressive
physical abilities however his dark hell
assassination style was no match for one
punch next we have elder centipede
definitely the strongest centipede I've
ever seen it towers over buildings when
it comes to size its defense is also
insane since a pumped-up metal bat and
s-class hero couldn't even crack its
exoskeleton nor could metal Knights
missiles
it can cause mass destruction due to its
strength and size and it can quickly
travel through the underground
it also has impressive regeneration
abilities since it could recover from
generals incinerating the inside of its
body
apparently blasts the mysterious number
one-ranked s-class hero
beat it two years ago but he didn't
succeed in killing the centipede and it
was even smaller than so elder centipede
comes back stronger than ever bang his
martial arts master brother bomb and
generals do not succeed in defeating it
but Saitama does with a glorious serious
punch it is impressive that Saitama
resorted to using a serious punch to
kill the elder centipede well we have to
remember he wanted to minimize
collateral damage he wanted to make sure
the centipede didn't get away again and
he was frustrated about losing so many
times to King in a video game earlier so
it was a way for him to blow off some
steam
thus the centipede that caused so much
trouble for so many S Class Heroes was
nothing but a defective punching bag for
Saitama next we had Phoenix man who has
one of my favorite backstories he was
just an actor who wore a bird costume
and was the mascot of a show called
animal Empire the character's name was
bird brain he was thick-headed so he
ended up dying all the time he was the
chicken kenny of the show and he'd just
be revived back in the next episode like
nothing happened the show ended up
getting canned
because there was so much dark humor
however even after the show the actor
kept a suit on and then underwent
monster vacation with it so he ended up
inheriting the abilities of the
fictional character from the show does
it make sense no but is it entertaining
definitely as a result when he's a
monster he can revive and he comes back
even stronger after child Emperor
defeats him the first time he comes back
as the dragon level Phoenix man
reincarnated and he looks way cooler
than he used to
as he said enduring the hell that lies
just short of death is the secret to
making a monster undergo explosive
growth which is true for Saiyans and I'd
argue for humans too what doesn't kill
you permanently makes you stronger
Phoenix man can now enter Hawk mode and
absorb energy based attacks and then
release the energy he absorbed his
Falcon mode allows him to fly even
quicker than usual after he resurrects
for the second time he enters the even
more powerful brilliant eagle mode the
coolest-looking form so far at this
point he's significantly more powerful
and he was already a dragon level threat
before even a super kamehameha from
child Emperor his strongest finishing
attack couldn't defeat him although the
power was so great that when Phoenix man
absorbed it it caused defect in his
mascot suit child Emperor clearly can't
beat him in power but he succeeds in
beating him with a tickle tickle bug
number one that got inside the Phoenix
suit and made it possible for child
Emperor to rip off the suit which is the
source of Phoenix Man's power the fight
between child Emperor and Phoenix man is
one of my favorites and I absolutely
can't wait to see it animated go pets
who had four eyes and he was an
executive member of the monster
Association he was a martial arts
fighter and the winner of the first
Super fight tournament he was challenged
and lost her monster king Orochi he was
brought back to Monster Association HQ
and eventually he was offered monster
cells and went through the process of
monster ization he didn't want to have
human limits anymore and he felt like
becoming a monster was the way to break
through those limits gain greater power
which would in turn allow him to take
everything he wants using violence he is
stronger than ever after becoming a
monster and is able to take out generals
with no problem go cats who can easily
PowerSuite you and even the dragon level
monster eyes Baku Zhan go cats whose
powers are straightforward his monster
ization enhanced his physical skills
increasing his strength durability and
speed by insane amounts so that he can
use his already impressive martial arts
skills much more effectively the great
irony of go cats whose life is that he
became a monster to surpass human limits
and then got one shotted by a human next
up we have Yan another executive member
of the monster association he is a cat
man of sorts he used to be a regular
house cat and he has PTSD because his
owner a little girl used to force her
love on him through hugs and kisses he
gained human-like intelligence when he
underwent monster ization he uses his
impressive speed and sharp claws to
fight he could get deep cuts into puddi
puddi prisoner's flesh before the latter
developed body hair that drastically
increased his defensive abilities
additionally Yan can pass through cracks
if they're more than three millimeters
wide he uses this ability to run away
from pooty pooty prisoner although Yan
is not the strongest he is smart and
knows when to flee for instance he went
full out and attacked Saito from behind
it did nothing and Yan quickly ran away
from Saitama before he attacked him back
thus when he knows he's beat he doesn't
worry about pride he just uses his
impressive speed and passing through
cracks ability to run away next we have
Goro Goro the eye monster with psychic
abilities it is said to be Ono Chiefs
closest advisor and the chief advisor of
the monster Association in truth Goro
Goro is a meat puppet for the dragon
level s per third eye psychos who is
actually the leader of the monster
association and the old friend of Pooh
Buki she was actually the vice president
of FUBU keys Blizzard group in high
school she saw a vision of the future
that drove her mad after seeing the
future she wanted to wipe out humanity
the Blizzard group and psychos parted
ways after that in psychos created the
monster association with or chicken she
turned on Archie from a human into a
monster and began to execute her plan
psychos aside from being able to
evaluate a person's strength and turn
them into powerful monsters can use her
impressive psychic abilities in battle
she can use psychic binding to suppress
the power of another Esper and multiply
the gravity
in an area even by 300 times in order to
crush our opponents she can create
psychic barriers to protect herself and
or condense surrounding wreckage around
her opponent in order to crush them
nevertheless she's no match for
tatsumaki which is why she used a number
of dragon level monsters to give her
brain damage so that tatsumaki psychic
power becomes unstable temporarily
unlucky for psychos though Tsubaki shows
up and even though she has less psychic
output compared to psychos she succeeds
in beating her by using her technique
psychic whirlwind which makes psychosis
attacks useless next up we have a roach
eat the monster king himself he used to
be human but after countless failures
and sacrifices he became the ultimate
being according to psychos his power far
exceeds that of most dragon level
monsters Orochi is a huge monster that
worse item I in size he can produce many
dragon heads and tentacles and use them
to attack his enemies he can shoot fire
from dragon heads which is how he burns
sytem escape his ultimate form looks
more human
but he still has Doc Ock like limbs and
dragon heads coming out all over his
body despite how scary and powerful he
was made to be he was defeated by a
normal punch from Saitama
and that was when the monster King
finally experienced fear for the first
time next we have gale wind and Hellfire
flame who are ninja from the same
village as speed of sound sonic and
flashy flash I love the names of all
these ninjas because they're always
unnecessarily repetitive obviously a
gale is a strong wind and hopefully I
don't have to explain why fire and flame
is repetitive I always get a kick out of
these ninja names I gotta say ninja are
strong to begin with so when they
undergo monster ization they become even
more powerful than most monsters in
their dragon level forms both gale wind
and Hellfire blaze don't even need their
blades to fight their special strength
is their speed and agility flashy flash
says the other s-class heroes would have
had trouble dealing with their speed
they can additionally use their
respective elements wind and fire to
further empower their attacks despite
all this though flashy flash manages to
take them both out at the
same time with a flashy slash it is an
epic moment and flashy flash says that
the two lost because they were lacking
in training this was such an epic fight
that flashy flash became one of my
favorite heroes after it overgrown Rover
is another dragon level monster and an
executive member of the Monster
Association he is a six eyed giant dog
he can shoot fiery energy blasts at his
opponents from his mouth these blasts
are strong enough to incinerate stone
and they can kill demon level monsters
in a single shot they can also destroy
many floors of the monster association
HQ even gar was best attack at the time
virtually had no effect against them
however Saitama as usual is another
story he tells the dog to sit while he
punches him he's trying to train him
rather than hurt him even though he
wasn't really trying with the punch
Rover remembers his training so when a
road she wants Rover to attack Saitama
Rover runs away instead fubu Keeffe
generals bang and bomb have trouble
taking on Rover later but managed to
deal with him by telling him to sit it
seems like Saitama straining was very
effective so much so in fact that later
Rover shrinks and Saitama mistakes him
for a lost dog
Saitama takes him into a city and even
protects him from the security system
eventually Saitama gives him to a class
heroes to take care of which is
hilarious since they have no idea that
their pet dog is strong enough to put S
Class Heroes to shame Fuhrer ugly is
another executive member of the monster
Association and the worst possible
opponent that sweet mask could ever face
aside from being strong pure ugly is
surprisingly fast even though he's obese
you can quickly jump from wall to wall
and has quick reflexes sweet mask is
even impressed by his speed and agility
like other fugly monsters to use sweet
masks term Fuehrer ugly became a monster
because of resentment his spiteful heart
was filled with years of social
difficulties all rooted on his repulsive
appearance the uglier he became on the
inside the stronger he got when he
monster eyes pure ugly especially hates
sweet maths because he is jealous of his
good looks and how he makes girls scream
but in a different way in contrast sweet
bass can't even fight him because when
he sees a hideous face he gets so
distressed that he
can't even move pure ugly can also make
his cells mutate and by doing so enter a
bigger and stronger form however even in
this form he is no match for our elder
bang when he gets serious
lastly believe it or not pure ugly has
been seen reading a book on how to
become popular it really makes you
wonder how he would have turned out if
he was born with sweet masks looks and
had his popularity next up we have gums
to giant eating machine he is a large
ball with a mouth for a head gums is
like the personification of the sin of
gluttony although I personally prefer
when the sin of gluttony looks like a
sexy thirty year old woman with magic
powers but realistically a gluttonous
obese monster like gums who doesn't even
talk what only consumes is really the
perfect image of gluttony he is the
monster equivalent of the s-class hero
Pig God he uses his immense strength to
overpower opponents and then eat and
digest them his teeth are strong enough
to bite through metal with ease
gums has elastic jaws and can swallow
someone as large as Pig God in a single
bite although pig God fights his way out
next we have homeless Emperor another
villain with a Great backstory he is an
executive member of the monster
Association as well he had it rough as a
human he had a company day job
his manager made him dance around naked
during a welcome party for new hires the
next morning he was accused of indecent
exposure and was fired on the spot he
lost his job lost his home and spent his
days camping in a park and despite all
this when he saw the wide open sky above
his head his resentment felt small and
petty
he realized that no building is a
spacious as the earth itself no interior
lighting was as majestic as the skies
humans are no more than specks of dust
scattered on this incredible being we
call our planet homeless Emperor viewed
the earth as his home the earth was a
house larger than the greatest Emperor's
largest palace according to homeless
Emperor he was enlightened and saw the
truth he couldn't understand why people
would tear themselves away from the
perfect ecosystem that took Mother Earth
millennia to construct it was absurd to
him that such fools who live alien ated
from nature would look down on him
finally he said I
wanted to opt out of this ugly
claustrophobic stupid gray world that
humanity built from the heights of their
stupidity I wanted to return to nature
to commune heart and soul with Mother
Earth and the only real way to achieve
that was to choose that then when he
came to that conclusion that's when God
apparently came to him right before his
eyes
this being agreed that humanity was
foolish but it was not time for homeless
Emperor to die this God figure granted
him power then homeless Emperor chose to
use that power to free the planet from
the parasite called humanity homeless
Emperor has the body of a normal person
so he's not well suited for close
hand-to-hand combat he is nonetheless
quick and he uses that speed in
combination with his energy balls to
both avoid attacks and launch attacks
his energy bolts are so strong that the
s-class zombie man has to admit that
homeless Emperor is overpowered his
energy balls are even strong enough to
temporarily take out bang but the most
interesting thing is that when he
finally gets captured by zombie man he
gets a vision where he is in a meadow
with a giant figure and that figure is
the being he calls God then his God not
only takes his powers away but also
takes his life his body is then
completely destroyed this is probably
one of the most mysterious moments in
the series although I can't talk about
it in great detail because we still
don't know a lot about this God figure
it definitely seems like he could be the
strongest antagonist we've seen so far
if we consider how he can create at
least dragon level monsters on his own
and how he can kill in such mysterious
ways
next we have executive member evil
natural water as the name suggests this
monster is a moving mass of water as a
result it can take any shape and move
any way at will evil natural water acts
on instinct and there's a rumour that it
responds to the killing intent of those
around it this is why it doesn't respond
to King because he is secretly terrified
inside evil natural waters so difficult
to control that even psychos kept it
locked up one of its strongest moves is
high-speed jet stream attack
it fires a jet of water that is quicker
and more powerful than a bullet this is
by far one of the deadliest and scariest
monsters you could deal with because of
its speed deadliness and near
invincibility it even survives a punch
from Saitama but eventually Pig God
succeeds in killing it by digesting it
it's actually hilarious before it's
digested evil natural water shoots all
these holes into Pig God then when told
that he should go to the hospital
immediately to heal himself Pig God says
that he'll stop by a ramen shop first
next up we have executive member black
sperm
you heard right he's called black sperm
and when it comes to strength he's no
joke in his goal and sperm form he's
considered to be the most powerful
monster in the Association besides
monster king larache he can split into
multiple clones and merge the clones
together to create more powerful
versions of himself his strongest
version is golden sperm which requires
at least 10 trillion cells to create in
this form sweet mask said that even if
all the S Class Heroes ganged up on
golden sperm it would still be a
difficult fight he was strong and fast
enough to overpower a weakened tatsumaki
and he was completely immune to her
psychic powers he also became very
arrogant and told all of the other
heroes to form a line and wait for their
turn to be killed eventually though
Garwood defeats golden sperm while a
single black sperm cell survives and
becomes a pet along with no longer
overgrown Rover kenzan rat or
needlepoint mouse is also a dragon level
monster that appeared later in the story
and attacked each city it is a giant rat
with giant spikes covering its entire
body it's like a Godzilla porcupine it's
likely that it's major strength was its
overwhelming size but we didn't see it
do too much it was accidentally killed
because it got caught in the crossfire
of a fight between Saitama and tatsumaki
now let's talk about gato
the former student of bang he is one of
the most interesting and longest lasting
villains in the series believe it or not
gato is only 18 years old he has been
called the human monster and the hero
hunter I absolutely loved his backstory
when I first heard it when he was a kid
he watched a superhero show called
Justice man unlike most kids
Garo hated justice man and he was always
rooting for the villains he got upset
because justice man would stop the
villain from conquering the world every
time the bad guys try so hard but always
get killed
to Garo that's unfair and boring the
villains have hopes to and they're
cooler Garo feels bad because he always
roots for them but they always lose as
he says popular guys winning and
unpopular guys losing is a tragedy
so godoh decides that he won't lose to
anyone and he'll become the strongest
villain and change the story after he
manages to beat a large group of a class
heroes and escape from generals bang and
bomb the hero Association labels garl a
dragon level monster by this time Goro
has awakened his half monster form with
its red right eye and red air however a
garbages keeps getting stronger he goes
on to defeat s-class heroes like Corey
pootie prisoner and dark shine he even
broke dark shrines self-confidence in
the process later in his awakened
monster form he claims that his
technique is disaster level God implying
that he has become a God level monster
the fact is it is a self-proclaimed
title so we can't definitively label him
as God level but his powers are truly
impressive at this point although he has
super strength speed durability and
regeneration his main strength really
lies in his explosive rate of growth his
technique which he calls monster
calamity God Slayer fist allows him to
quickly overpower s-class heroes like
atomic samurai pig God we can tatsumaki
and more during his fight with Saitama
Gaara undergoes more monstrous
transformations nevertheless he is
powerless against Saitama godoh reveals
that he is actually fighting for world
peace he believes that absolute evil can
establish real peace while Humanity is
fear and Garo the monster everyone's
hearts will unite to survive he feels
like that is his duty and he asks
Saitama why he's a hero and site to my
answers after picking his nose that it's
a hobby
Garo freaks out at how unfair it is that
someone with Saitama strength has no
strong sense of duty like he does then
Saitama reveals that what girl always
wanted to be was a hero he even had an
image of an ideal hero inside him even
though most of the heroes wanted to kill
him Saitama did not and in the end he
lets him get away
so Goro lives to fight another day but
perhaps now he will begin to work toward
an ideal hero rather than an ideal
monster and here's two bonus dragon
level monsters that didn't appear in the
manga
there's the anime only dragon level
monster pluton king of the underworld
who looks like a giant pig holding a
trident his screen time is very short
his motivation is that he wants to
destroy humans because they waste their
existence in gluttony and littered the
earth with worthless objects he is
another Godzilla ask giant monster that
can destroy cities however Saitama
quickly deals with him and all it takes
is one punch
then there's energizer who appeared in
an audio book so we have no image of him
he can shoot energy blasts like other
monsters we've seen energizer was pretty
strong speed Oh Sonic needed Saito must
help to defeat him so the two teamed up
and that is it for today's video
thank you so much for watching I truly
think that villains are usually much
more interesting than heroes so I really
enjoy doing the research on all these
different villains make sure to smash
that like button if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more like it let
me know what other one punch man videos
you would like to see in the comments a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I especially want
to thank our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings eldress and angel
Cruz and are the one tier patron still
ones who stand atop all clans baby Rey
a17 FF TP Steven and Radha a Lola naught
M Matty Mac 239 makoto-kun and keelon
and the patrons who transcend greatness
itself Regan Harrison and Lorne oxen or
the chosen few who have been
acknowledged by a lord we go himself if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon.com slash
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these real-life heroes right
here and you'll get access to our
private patient only discord so check
out patreon.com/lenguin
and until next time see us space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]